Immer wieder finden forschungsteams weltweit hinweise darauf dass gänseblümchen auf der wiese oder die küchenkräuter in ihrer küche mehr können als
Einfach nur grün zu sein und zu wachsen es scheint manchmal so als hätten sie eine art
Seelenleben es gibt einige expertinnen und experten
Die überzeugt davon sind dass pflanzen gefühle haben und ein gedächtnis ihr habt euch dieses thema
Dieses hoch spannenden thema bei whatsapp gewünschte bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts zum thema
Können sich pflanzen tot stellen oder freuen sie sich über frisches wasser und was hat das all das mit
Dem lügendetektor des amerikanischen geheimdienstes, zu tun jetzt den klicks zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Erst vor kurzem haben wir hier über die theorie des sogenannten wood wide web berichtet das internet des waldes denn mittlerweile steht fest
bäume
Kommunizieren nicht nur über duft botschaften sondern auch über pilze konkret handelt es sich um sogenannte mykorrhiza
Weiße pilzfäden die tatsächlich mit dem fein wurzelsystem der bäume kontakt aufnehmen und botschaften an andere
pflanzen sträucher und bäume übermitteln konkret transportieren sie wasser
kohlenstoff und nährstoffe zwischen den bäumen hin und her und zwar ganz individuell abgestimmt auf die verschiedenen bedürfnisse
dazu der zellbiologe
frantisek baluska von der universität bonn beuel haben ihre eigenen probleme ihre eigenen fähigkeiten mit problemen umzugehen
schon sehr früh hatte der amerikaner keith baxter die idee von solchen fähigkeiten der pflanzen
er hatte in den frühen 50er jahren für den amerikanischen geheimdienst eine
lügendetektor schule gegründet mittlerweile gilt er als vater der pflanzen
kommunikation aber wie passt das zusammen ganz einfach in einer winternacht
Im jahr 1966 kam tief baxter auf die idee sein neues lügendetektor verfahren auch an seiner, büro pflanze
zu testen wie reagiert der drachenbaum wohl was zeigt der schreiber des lügendetektor sven mann der pflanze wasser gibt wächst
erwartete eine kurve die einen kleineren
elektrischen widerstand anzeigt denn die pflanze sollte eine bessere leitfähigkeit haben wenn sie gerade frisch
Gegossen wurde dazu baxter, ich weiß nicht mehr wie so aber aus irgendeinem
Grund wollte ich wissen wie lange wohl das wasser brauchen würde um
Aus dem wurzelbereich bis ganz nach oben in die spitzen der blätter, zu gelangen
Doch die kurve die ihm dann angezeigt wurde ließ ihm den atem stocken es war genau die typische kurve die das gerät
anzeigte wenn menschen positiv erregt worden waren die pflanze freute sich also über das wasser
baxter verbrachten die ganze nachbar samen drachenbaum in einem nächsten test wollte
Er die pflanze bedrohen also dachte er daran ein blatt an zu brennen wechselt zufolge reagiert die pflanze bereits in diesem moment äußerst
Krass also bereits in der sekunde als er nur daran dachte die pflanze zu verletzen hatte die pflanze ist also
bemerkt dass man sie in gedanken bedrohte griff baxter ging
Also, los um streichhölzer
zu holen wieder zeigte der
lügendetektor eine angst kurve einen schwächeren ausschlag folgte dann als besser ein blatt an fackelte doch der amerikaner bekam es nicht übers herz
Seine pflanze zu verbrennen und so tat er in den darauf folgenden versuchen nur noch, so als wolle
er den drachen baum verletzten die pflanze reagierte gar nicht wahr der drachenbaum also tatsächlich in der lage zu verstehen
Wann er ernsthaft in gefahr ist und wann die bedrohung nur ein testlauf ist die aufzeichnung, des
lügendetektor von den reaktionen des drachen baum schmückten kurze zeit
Später wächst das wand und der chl mitarbeiter ging noch weiter
denn
Er wollte testen ob seine pflanze auch die gedanken und gefühle anderer lebewesen lesen kann dazu ließ er
Leben des schirms in kochendes wasser werfen und ja der baum hatte mitleid, zudem fand heraus dass die hühnereier
Schmerzempfinden wenn sie gekocht werden und salatblätter in todes starre fallen kurz bevor sie gegessen werden und auch heute noch
Gibt es einige forschungsteams die sich becks hat zumindest in teilen anschließen es ist also keine wissenschaftlich
bestätigte lehrmeinung also ganz wichtig aber laut diesen forschungsteams haben pflanzen gefühle können sich erinnern und optische und akustische
eindrücke wahrnehmen und auch menschen aus buddhistischen ländern sind auf baxter seite doch nicht nur die cia
kritisierte baxter für seine experimente auch die meisten forschungsteams weltweit sehen seine ergebnisse nicht und tatsächlich bisher konnten becks dass ergebnisse nicht
wirklich in experimenten
reproduziert werden
Wenn er als erstes neues über das geheime leben der pflanzen und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei wurden dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt ihr direkt über mich in der redaktion von klicks zum mitmachen und
mir themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und somit bestimmen was sie auf tricks um
Läuft und es gibt auch ein kleines goodie, am anfang der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter dafür auch. Draufklicken mit können pflanzen denken ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran